an Epic Production like the Indiana
Jones Series is truly a collaboration
and a big part of that is Johnny
Williams score his
gave such detail to every single
heart-stopping moment and bonded all of
these films together and gave these
films a musical identity
that scene that in three notes you're
gonna recognize he just has that
signature in what he does
John's music
in parallel
it's just incredible how original and
how powerful the themes are that John
creates for each element of the film
I have been fortunate enough to be
associated with the films over quite a
long period of time to with each film
add more to the collection of musical
material
no if John would do the whole movie I
only prayed at first he said I'll write
some themes and then he just couldn't
stop writing all the music to the movie
good afternoon everyone thank you for
coming this afternoon
the saying that I never get over it is
how you sit on a scoring stage and John
raises his baton
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
tribute to the power of Orchestra
[Music]
[Applause]